>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Elizabeth Peterson:
Hello, everyone and welcome
and thanks for making it.
Is it, okay.
I'm Betsy Peterson, the director of
the American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress
and I want to welcome you
to the latest presentation in the
Botkin [phonetic] lecture series.
The Botkin series allows
the American Folklife Center
to present the latest
scholarship, the best scholarship
in the disciplines of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history,
cultural heritage, and
other cultural studies.
It also allows us the opportunity
to enhance our collections.
Each of these lectures
are videotaped.
They do make their
way into our archive
and eventually make their way up
onto our website so that individuals
around the world can hear
and learn from these lectures
and future generations
can hear as well.
So if you have a device turned
on, a cell phone, etcetera,
etcetera, please turn it off now.
And today it is my pleasure to
introduce a multitalented writer,
critic musician, Elijah Wald.
Dr. Wald, I should say, is
originally from the Boston area
and he began his career
as a folk blues guitarist,
and he did well traveling
the world and being abroad
for roughly a decade fronting
a blues band in Seville, Spain,
a swing trio in Antwerp,
and a rock band in Colombo,
Sri Lanka before returning
to the United States
to continue his music here.
He's released two solo
albums, played on as a musician
on numerous others, and still
remains active as a musician.
But as I think many of us
know, Elijah has another life
and he is equally well-known as
a writer, critic, and scholar,
and it is in this capacity
that he is joining us today.
Since the 1980's Elijah has gained
wide renowned as a writer on roots
and world music and he's written for
numerous newspapers and magazines,
most notably the Boston Globe where
he published over a 1,000 articles
until he left the paper in 2000.
He has also authored more than
a dozen influential books,
and I'll just name a couple here,
Escaping the Delta, Robert Johnson
and the Invention of the Blues, How
the Beatles Destroyed Rock 'n Roll,
An Alternative History of American
Popular Music, and Narcocorrido,
A Journey into the Music of Guns
-- Drugs, Guns, and Guerrillas.
The Mayor of MacDougal Street
is a memoir that he co-authored
with Dave Van Rock, and it
served as the inspiration
for the Cohen brothers
movie Inside Llewyn Davis.
And I must say it's
better than the movie.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> He has won a Grammy
award for the album notes
to The Arhoolie Records
40th Anniversary Box Set,
for which he was also
nominated as a producer.
His other awards include
an ASCAP Deems Taylor award
and an honorable mention
for the American musicological
society's Otto Kinkelday award,
my apologies.
Elijah also holds an
interdisciplinary Ph.D.
in ethnomusicology
and sociolinguistics,
which I think is a fairly recent --
>> As of today.
>> Degree, okay.
Congratulations.
And he has also taught
for several years
in the Musicology Department
at UCLA.
So without further ado we're
delighted to have Elijah Wald
with us today and please
join me in welcoming Elijah.
[ Applause ]
I should also say Elijah will
talk for roughly an hour.
We'll have some questions
and that will be followed
by a book signing out in the lobby.
And we hope you will go out
and buy one of the books.
So take it away.
>> Elijah Wald: Okay, I will
take it as far as I can.
Okay, yeah.
So I'm going to be
talking about Dylan,
but I'm also more generally talking
a bit about how we do history.
And I want to start by saying what
historians do is we tell stories.
For those of you who speak French or
Spanish it's in fact the same word,
[speaking foreign language]
history or story.
And I think that's an
important point to make,
because history is not
what happened in the past.
History is the process of organizing
what we know about the past
into stories that are
relevant to us in the present.
And what that means is
that history is not static,
it's constantly changing
because what's relevant to us
in the present is changing.
And the Dylan story, we've all --
we all know the standard Dylan
story I suspect in this room.
The standard story is he came
to New York as a folk singer
in very much Woody
Guthrie's tradition.
He became the new young voice
of the folk protest movement.
He then switched to writing more
poetic introspective lyrics,
which irritated a lot of
the people who loved him
as a folk protest singer,
and then at Newport
in 1965 he declared his
independence from the folk scene
and the boring old folkies
didn't understand and booed him.
But he was an artist
and went his own way
and history has proved him right.
Now I don't disagree with any
of that, but it is history
as it was written in a particular
moment in the second half
of the 1960's as part of announcing
the arrival of rock and roll
as a mature, serious art form.
And in that history, which has
remained the standard Dylan history,
he is first and foremost a
song writer, and indeed a poet.
But what I'm going to be
talking about today is sort
of a different story because
I was on a different mission.
My question was about Dylan's
choice to go electric at Newport,
and that's not a decision made as a
songwriter, that's a decision made
as a musician and performer.
And once I started thinking
about, so okay, let's get away
from the songwriting and discuss
who Dylan was as a musician
and performer, I was immediately
struck by a sort of bizarre fact
in the Dylan story, which is the
way everyone talked about Dylan
when he first became known as,
well he's not a great singer,
he's not a great guitar player,
but he's such an incredible writer
that it surmounts all
of these weaknesses.
But in 1961 Dylan became the
first young male folksinger
in Greenwich Village to ever get
a profile in the New York Times,
or to be ever signed by
a major record label,
and at that point he had
only written two songs,
neither of which was particularly
interesting, and was signed
and written up as a musician and
performer, not as a songwriter.
So if his strength was as a
songwriter and he was deficient
as a musician, how did that happen?
And also the way we
all hear the story is
at that point he was
a Woody Guthrie clone,
but the New York Times story
doesn't mention Woody Guthrie.
It compares him to
Blind Lemon Jefferson,
the Texas blues musician
from the 1920's.
Now if that was right then the
story of Dylan deciding in 1965
to go electric with the Paul
Butterfield Blues Band sounds
like a completely different story.
If we've got somebody who in 1961
was a Blind Lemon Jefferson style
blues singer and now he's teaming
up with the Butterfield Band.
Now it's not quite
that simple, but --
sorry, that wasn't supposed
to happen, but it did.
In any case, this is Dylan with his
original band, The Golden Chords.
You will notice the
ad of Monte Edwardson,
Leroy Hoikkala, and Bobby Zimmerman.
And what he sounded like at
that point was this [music].
But we need that to
be much, much louder.
[ Music ]
His main instrument at that point
was piano rather than guitar,
and he was planning
to be Little Richard.
And the next thing in fact that
happens on that tape is an argument
between him and one of his friends,
because the friend is saying
nice things about Elvis Presley
and Dylan is saying, no, no,
you have to listen to real guys
who Elvis Presley imitated,
Clyde McPhatter
and Ray Charles and The Drifters.
In fact, we can do the picture.
Yes, the real guys
and the fake guys.
You will notice that
there is a difference
between the real guys
and the fake guys.
Like many teenagers, young
Bobby Zimmerman was trying
to define himself and that
concept of authenticity,
which regularly comes in in
the Dylan at Newport story.
I'm just trying to make the point
he was in that concept already
at this point but in
a different world.
And that whole idea of authenticity,
what that's about is there are a few
of us who know the real
stuff, unlike that mass
of stupid people out
there who don't.
And that's really the entire
discourse of authenticity.
You can phrase it all
sorts of other ways,
but that's basically
what it's about.
Dylan grew up in northern
Minnesota in a town
with not a single African-American
resident, I have checked the census.
And he discovered this secret
world of music that he could access
on the radio late at night coming
out of Shreveport, Louisiana.
And knowing about that
music set him apart.
And when he met anyone else who
knew about that music it was sort
of like they were members
of a secret club.
Now that's not a new idea.
It's one of the stock
cliches of rock history,
that there was this secret world
that young, specifically white,
specifically usually male listeners
were discovering late night
on the radio and that
that changed America.
That cliche typically
connects this rebel music
with other rebel elements of
that period, and Dylan fits
that discourse perfectly.
By the time I was a teenager
learning about all of this,
that rock and roll, James Dean rebel
attitude was also often being linked
to the alienation of Jack
Kerouac and The Beats.
But that's an anachronism.
That link happened after Dylan.
And Kerouac and The Beats
were not into rock and roll.
They came up in the 1940's listening
to modern jazz and classical music.
Kerouac's writing is full of
references to Brahms, Beethoven,
Shostakovich, and Stravinsky.
That is, they were rebels
but they were grown-ups
and they listened to grown-up music.
And in the '50s and early '60s rock
and roll was not grown-up music.
If you were in favor of it you were
saying it was fun, it was exciting,
it was energetic, but it was music
for kids and poor uneducated people.
Even people who liked
rock took it for granted.
This is one the fascinating
things you find reading people,
reading interviews in this
period, took it for granted
that if they went to college
they would start listening
to more mature kinds of music.
And classical and jazz
were the most familiar.
And by the late '50s folk
music had joined them.
And indeed by the 1960 when Dylan
moved to Minneapolis and started
at the university there, folk music
had become the defining collegiate
style thanks to the Kingston
Trio and the dozens of groups
that followed in their wake.
Now it may sound a little strange
for me to talk about modern jazz
and folk music overlapping,
but that in fact was a reality.
I mean a typical record collection
that had the Kingston Trio
would also have Dave Brubeck
and very likely Miles Davis.
And in fact one of the interesting
facts of American music history is
that the Kingston Trio actually made
their east coast debut in New York
and the Village Vanguard on a
double bill with Thelonious Monk.
They did two weeks as a double bill.
That is the Kingston Trio were
fun, but they were the fun music
that the smart kids listened to.
And the Newport Folk Festival
fits perfectly in this.
It was an offshoot of the
Newport Jazz Festival.
It was in fact originally
planned as an afternoon
at the Newport Jazz
Festival and then sort
of became its own festival.
So when Dylan went off to college he
was following an absolutely normal
transition going into folk music,
but as somebody who had been an R
and B purist who didn't like white
rock and roll, it's interesting
to notice that if you read
Dylan's description of this period,
the artists who first got him
into folk music is this list.
And if you look at his repertoire
that's who he is singing,
he's singing Odetta and
Leon Bibb principally.
And it may just be coincidental,
but in that context it's sort
of interesting that the first Woody
Guthrie album he mentions ever
having, this was the cover.
I don't want to make
too much of that,
but I'm just -- it's interesting.
Now when he discovered Woody
Guthrie and Ramblin Jack Elliott,
he did change his style profoundly
and he got very much
into sounding like that.
But again, this story has often
been told in a particular way
with him becoming the next
songwriter after Woody.
So I'd want to point
out that this record,
which was the first Woody
Guthrie record he had,
and which in the Minneapolis
crowd was described
as Woody Guthrie's greatest work,
has only one original song on it.
Woody Guthrie was being
heard in this world
as an authentic folk voice
singing old folk songs.
Likewise, Jack Elliott normally
comes into this story as a link
to Woody Guthrie, but Jack
Elliott sang a lot of other stuff.
And the stuff that you most
profoundly hear Jack's influence
on Dylan is stuff like this.
No, that's not the track [music].
Sorry, that was that.
Here we go.
[ Music ]
That's actually Dylan, but it might
as well be Ramblin
Jack it's so close.
And that's what Dylan sounded
like when he arrived
in Greenwich Village.
That song is by Jesse Fuller,
a black blues performer,
but virtually everyone
in the folk scene
in that period got it
through Jack Elliott.
And Dylan came to New York
to visit Woody Guthrie,
who by then was his hero.
Again, this is a story that's
a little more complicated
than it's normally told, because
his huge devotion to Woody Guthrie,
the music was part of
it, but a huge part
of it was having read
Bound for Glory.
And I can speak for myself on
this one for an awful lot of us,
Woody Guthrie more than anything
else was the character Woody Guthrie
created for himself in Bound
for Glory, and Dylan showed
up in Greenwich Village
playing blues,
playing some of Woody's songs,
but profoundly he showed
up being Woody Guthrie.
He showed up as an orphan from the
western plains who had left home
when he was 13 and bummed around
the country playing in carnivals
and burlesque houses and bars
and had picked up his music
from people he had
met along the way.
The character in Bound for Glory,
as he put it in his first interview,
I sing old jazz songs,
sentimental cowboy songs,
top 40 hit parade stuff, people
have to name it something
so they call it folk music.
And that's a really interesting
statement because he's already,
at that moment in 1960,
setting himself apart
from the young urban kids on
the folk scene who are trying
to sing this music of the folk.
He's being a folk who
sings all kinds of music.
And that's something I had
completely misunderstood.
Or rather, it's something
I never paid attention
to because I'd already absorbed the
idea of him as part of this world
of the urban people who
were playing the folk music.
And what changed my whole
picture of who Dylan was,
was talking to Peter Stampfel.
I don't know how many
of you know this name.
He is a crazed druggie,
brilliant, wonderful human being
who had a band called the Holy
Modal Rounders and later the Fugs,
and he and Dylan and Jim
Kweskin actually worked some
as a trio back in that first year.
And when I asked him about when he
first saw Dylan he said it changed
his life, because Dylan was playing
hillbilly music like it was rock
and roll, and Peter had always
thought that the two great loves
of his life, rock and
roll and hillbilly music,
were completely separate worlds
and here was somebody proving
that they could be the same thing.
When I heard that it made
no sense whatsoever to me.
I had heard early Dylan.
It didn't sound at all like rock
and roll, but Peter is a genius
so Dave Van Rock, my mentor,
famously said Peter Stampfel is
undoubtedly some kind of genius,
just nobody has yet figured
out what kind, which is true.
But anyway, so I went home and
grabbed Dylan's first album
and decided to listen through one
and God damn it, there it was.
[ Music ]
Some of the younger people
in the room may not
instantly recognize that riff.
That's from the biggest hit of 1958.
[ Music ]
Which Dylan has repurposed.
So I thought, damn,
I've made a discovery.
Then I read the liner notes.
They say the diesel-tempoed
Highway 51 is
of a type sung by the
Everly Brothers.
I read the rest of the liner
notes, they list Dylan's influences
as Woody Guthrie, Hank
Williams, Jelly Roll Morton,
Carl Perkins, and early
Elvis Presley.
Now I've owned that
album for over 40 years.
I never noticed that.
I've read those liner notes over and
over, so why didn't I notice that?
The answer was because I knew
when I first got that Dylan album
that he was a folkie in
a scene that hated rock
and roll and hated Elvis Presley.
So I simply glossed over that
as I read it over and over.
But what if that wasn't true?
What if Columbia Records and
Bob Dylan were listing his links
to Elvis Presley on
that first album,
because that in fact was something
that would make him more appealing?
That doesn't fit the
standard Dylan story at all.
And it sounds crazy to all of
us who heard this first album
as the precursor to Freewheelin
and The Times They Are a Changin.
But now I'd like to
do a little question.
How many of you own Dylan's
first album, this album?
Okay, hold -- keep your
hands up for a second.
How many of you was that the
first Dylan album you had?
There you go, virtually
all the hands went down.
We all went back to this album
after we already had heard the Dylan
of The Times They Are A
Changin and Freewheelin.
And so we had this story
that he had done that
and then he did Freewheelin
and this was Dylan.
But in fact Freewheeling
wasn't the next thing
that Dylan did after this album.
The next thing Dylan did after this
album in January of 1962 was this.
[ Music ]
Stop that.
Go away.
[ Music ]
Okay, so if Dylan sounded like that
in 1962 why the hell was it news
that he went electric in 1965?
The answer is, nobody
heard that single,
and in fact nobody listened
to Dylan's first album.
The way everybody discovered
Dylan was this record [music].
No, not that record, go away.
What the hell was --
what the hell is that?
That was really weird.
This record.
[ Music ]
That was how virtually
everybody discovered Bob Dylan.
And by the time we heard him
we already knew he played
that kind of music.
He had a lousy voice compared
to Peter, Paul, and Mary,
but it was that kind of stuff.
It was called folk music,
but it didn't sound a lot
like Woody Guthrie or Ramblin
Jack Elliott or Dave Van Rock
or Blind Lemon Jefferson or
God knows, Elvis Presley.
What it sounded like was a record
that had been the number one hit
a dozen years earlier, of 1950,
a record that sounded like this.
Let's see if this time
it sounds less squeaky.
[ Music ]
So that's the huge hit of
1950, and that's The Weavers,
and the guy sitting on the floor
playing a banjo is Pete Seeger.
Now we tend to hear Seeger's story
told in a particular way as well.
He was a political folksinger,
a friend of Woody Guthrie,
together they formed a
political folk singing group
in the early 1940's
called The Almanac Singers.
Then 1950 he formed The Weavers.
They were blacklisted.
He bravely stood up to [inaudible],
the House on American
Activities Committee.
And by the 1960's he was the
grand old man of the folk scene.
In the Dylan story he's the
guy who tried to grab an axe
and cut the cable when Dylan
went electric at New Port.
So it's a bit surprising to
hear that lush pop orchestration
on Goodnight Irene, which many
of us had forgotten existed,
and to introduce Pete Seeger as
somebody who got number one hits
and founded the pop folk style.
But Pete Seeger was
a complicated guy.
In 1950 when that record
hit he was 31 years old
and still virtually unknown except
to folk music and folk dance fans
around Greenwich Village.
In fact, the year that he hit
with The Weavers was also the year
that his first ever solo album
appeared, it was this record,
and this record is extremely
important historically,
though it has largely
been forgotten.
This was the first time ever that
an urban educated musician attempted
to present folksongs the way
they were actually played
in rural communities.
Up until this time all the
people popularizing folk music
for urban audiences
had been changing it,
adapting it to fit the habits of
people who were used to listening
to classical and pop music.
And very much the way The Weavers
approach, the Joan Baez approach,
the Peter, Paul, and Mary
approach, but Pete had written
and self-published an
instructional book on how
to play southern mountain
banjo styles,
and his solo album was a
showcase for his belief
that traditional rural music
was not just raw material,
that you could take and
turn into concert music,
but in fact was a fully
achieved art created by important
and often virtuosic artists.
And that sounded very,
very different
from the smooth harmonies
of The Weavers.
The way this record
sounded was like this.
[ Music ]
And this set off a revolution, a
whole generation of young players,
Tom Paley notably among them,
the New Law City Ramblers,
Dave Van Rock, who dubbed this group
the neo ethnics, started trying
to play this music
authentically, not like Burl Ives
or Richard Dyer Bennett
or Susan Reed,
but the way people actually played
it down south where it came from.
And Pete very much was
a hero for this world,
and he very much fitted that.
I mean, he was a man who had just
built his own log cabin house,
cutting down the trees
on his own land.
I mean, he was very much
trying to sort of live this
in a lot of different ways.
And for him that was very much
connected to his politics,
to populism, communism, democracy.
The idea that folk artists were
not primitives, they were just
as important, intelligent,
mature, valuable,
virtuosic as concert artists.
I just -- I cut a moment out
of this talk and I just want
to see where I end up next.
Okay, now I know, yeah.
And the thing is, the way Pete
Seeger first heard folk music was
his father took him down to
the Asheville Folk Festival,
and he was in love with the
music, but also he was entranced
by the way the music seemed to fit
into the community and it seemed
to represent the lives of
the people who was making it.
And he had this idea of this music
as being inseparable
from the community.
And one of his great missions
was to encourage people
to make their own music
in their own communities,
rather than just consuming
music made by professionals,
including professionals who
might be marketed as folksingers.
And that's one of the things
that's really easy to misunderstand
about Pete Seeger, that for him a
bunch of people getting together
to play string quartets or
to sing doo-wop was as much
or more his mission than
people going and sitting
in a concert watching someone
on stage singing Barbara Allen.
Anyway, this brings us to
the Newport Folk Festival.
The first two Newport
Folk Festivals in 1959
and 1960 were basically
just big concerts.
They were like the
Newport Jazz Festival.
They were mostly made
up of professional performers
from the New York area.
But in 1960 Pete Seeger
did something interesting.
He requested George Wein, the
producer of the festivals,
to not pay him and to use the money
saved by not paying him to bring
down Jean Carignan, a
French-Canadian fiddler.
And driving back from that
festival Toshi Seeger, Pete's wife,
had the idea what could you do
if you could persuade
all the stars to do that?
And in 1963 they sat
down with George Wein
and designed a festival
on that principle.
The idea of the Newport
Folk Festivals from '63 on,
which everybody got
$50, known or unknown,
and because they had
some heavyweights
like Pete Seeger behind it, people
like Pete Seeger, Joan Baez,
The [inaudible], Theodore Bikel,
Peter, Paul, and Mary agreed to work
for $50 a day, which meant
that there was all the extra
money you could use to bring
in unknown performers like Doc
Watson, Mississippi John Hurt,
neither of those names anybody new
until they appeared
at Newport in 1963.
Bill Munro, John Lee
Hooker, who were known
within their own communities
but had never been presented
to folk music audiences.
The first Cajun band ever
presented outside rural Louisiana.
This all happened at Newport in '63,
and also some unknown new
young faces like Judy Collins
and Tom Paxton and Bob Dylan.
And there was some explicitly
political singers who were
at Newport, but again, this is
something that I had misunderstood,
because one of the other things
Pete Seeger did in this period,
he cofounded a newsletter called
Broadside Magazine in New York
and a lot of young songwriters,
including Bob Dylan started
writing a lot of political songs
to get published in Broadside.
And because histories
of the folk scene tend
to be very New York centric,
and to a degree Dylan centric,
when we talk about protest music
in the '60s there's a tendency
to immediately think of Bob Dylan
and Phil Ochs and Tom Paxton.
But in Pete Seeger's mind, when
he wanted to bring protest music
to Newport in 1963, that was
not what he was thinking about.
This is Pete Seeger doing a song --
doing the introduction at Newport
in '63 to the political group.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
Yeah, and the iconic moment
of that festival was the
grand finale on Friday night.
And that's a picture that it's
easy to misread in retrospect.
But what that picture is,
is you have the young stars
of the folk scene over here, Peter,
Paul, and Mary and Joan Baez,
and the grand old men of the folk
scene over on the other side,
Pete Seeger and Theodore
Bikel, fresh off starring
in the Broadway run
of the Sound of Music.
And in the middle you have the
unknown young figures representing
the voice of young America, Bob
Dylan and The Freedom Singers.
And they're linking
arms and singing Blowing
in the Wind and We Shall Overcome.
And that was the image of
protest at that moment.
The big issue of 1963
was civil rights.
And when Dylan became
associated with protest songs
that was the association he had
written Blowing in the Wind,
which was heard by a lot of
people up north as an anthem
of the civil rights movement, and
a month later in August 1963 he
and Joan Baez appeared at the march
on Washington with
Martin Luther King.
Now my time is limited, so I'm
going to now make a lateral jump
across the Atlantic to England.
In England the world had
looked very different
in the 1950's and into
the early '60s.
England was still recovering
from World War II.
World War II had been great
for the United States.
The U.S. had come out
the strongest, richest,
healthiest country in the world.
England had been bombed
to smithereens.
It was dark.
It was cold.
It was miserable.
There was no work.
Everything was rationed.
And the United States looked
very bright and exciting and fun,
Hollywood movies, the
music, all of that.
And it was this huge romantic
attraction to everything American
for young people in England.
And one result of that was they
weren't drawing all the lines
between different kinds of American
culture that we drew over here.
So, for example, the banjo player of
Ken Collier's New Orleans jazz band,
a guy named Lonnie Donegan,
was on the brakes playing
Woody Guthrie songs.
This was not something that happened
at jazz concerts in
the United States.
But weirdly enough, he
proceeded to get a hit
with Leadbelly's Rock Island Line
that also went top 10 over here
and started a whole style
of music called skiffle,
and a whole generation of young
Englishmen started playing skiffle
music, and that included teenagers,
who a few years later were
forming groups like The Beatles
and The Rolling Stones
and Led Zeppelin.
There's a wonderful YouTube
video of Jimmy Page at age 14
with his skiffle group explaining
to the interviewer that he wants
to grow up to do biomedical
research.
I really recommend this.
And they were playing American
hillbilly and blues songs
and listening to Ramblin Jack
Elliott and Woody Guthrie
and the Memphis Jug Band,
if they could get it,
but also to the electric blues
of Muddy Waters, Chris Barber,
the trombone player
in Ken Collier's band.
Oh, I see, you can't
see Lonnie Donegan.
He's not worth seeing anyway.
Ken Collier brought Muddy Waters'
electric band over to England
and had them on double bills
with his New Orleans
traditional jazz group.
And Chuck Berry started coming over
to them as Chess Records music.
I mean, The Rolling Stones
thought of Chuck Berry
and Muddy Waters as the same thing.
It's that Chess Records thing.
Over here that was
not the same thing.
And by 1963 they were
listening to Bob Dylan.
And then this came back
across the Atlantic,
and suddenly the number one hit
in the United States is the Animals
doing House of the Rising Sun,
which they've learned off
Bob Dylan's first record,
which no one over here
had paid any attention to,
and we call this the
British invasion.
There are all these British
rockers who were superstars
and they worshipped Bob Dylan.
The Beatles, this was
-- in Melody Maker,
it's Britain's most
popular music newspaper,
and the whole interview they're
saying yeah, we really think we need
to sound more like Bob Dylan
and be more like Bob Dylan.
We love his attitude.
He doesn't seem to
care about anything
and he just goes his own way.
And British fans were also cutting
electric versions of Dylan hits.
This one is one of the less
familiar and more wonderful ones.
It's with Jimmy Page on guitar
by a group called The Fairies.
[ Music ]
>> Year?
>> Elijah Wald: Now -- '64.
Now that singing style makes
an other interesting link,
because another huge hit over
here in 1964, I've never seen,
even on the internet
they don't connect this
to Don't Think Twice It's Alright,
which is really weird,
because listen to it.
[ Music ]
Next to Ring of Fire that was Johnny
Cash's biggest hit of the 1960's,
and it's just Don't
Think Twice It's Alright.
So you can see how at this point Bob
Dylan might be thinking there was
space for him on the top 40.
Which brings us to the
1965 Newport Folk Festival.
Ah so, no, it doesn't.
It brings us to his next album
where he goes electric, excuse me,
Bringing It All Back Home.
In 1965 he brings out this
album with the cover photo
of him looking hip,
rich, and intense,
and electric instrumentation
on one side,
and that album title was framed
explicitly by Columbia Records
as Dylan is the answer
to the British invasion.
They have been doing American
music and been selling it to us,
but we've got the real thing and
Dylan is bringing it all back home.
That brings us to the
Newport Folk Festival,
where once again the bill included
Pete Seeger, Joan Baez, Dylan,
Peter, Paul, and Mary, The Freedom
Singers, Mississippi John Hurt,
Doc Watson, Bill Monroe,
a lot of familiar faces,
a lot of people coming back to
spend a sunny weekend listening
to the music they loved,
surrounded by other people
who shared their tastes and beliefs.
But during that first evening's
concert they got something very
different than what they
had been used to at Newport.
It sounded like this.
[ Music ]
How do you think the
folkies reacted to that one?
Alan Lomax, the conservative dean of
hard core American folklorist jumped
on stage as soon as the Chambers
Brothers finished playing,
seized the mic and said, I'm very
proud tonight that we finally got
onto the Newport Folk
Festival stage,
our modern American folk
music rock and roll.
Okay, so how does that square
with our picture of Alan Lomax,
the guy who hated electric
music in general
and rock and roll in particular?
Well, the answer is that's
simply flat out wrong.
Alan Lomax in 1959 at Carnegie
Hall presented Muddy Waters
with electric backing
and a doo-wop group.
He wanted The Cadillacs, the guys
who did Speedo, but they didn't show
up so he got a less known group.
And he took great pride
in how horrified a lot
of the folk fans were by
this, but his whole point,
which he had been arguing
for years, is real folk music
in New York is what black
kids are doing in Harlem,
not a bunch of college
kids with banjos trying
to pretend they're hillbillies
in Washington Square Park.
That's why he objected to
The Butterfield Blues Band,
who he famously objected
to at Newport.
He was the guy who had discovered
Muddy Waters in Mississippi.
He knew real Chicago blues.
He appreciated real Chicago blues,
and the first real Chicago
blues band to be brought
to Newport was a bunch of white
college kids, that was his problem
with The Butterfield Band.
Now personally I love
The Butterfield Band,
and I want to underline a point here
which is, one of the big problems
with the way music
history is often done is
that people confuse music
history with music criticism
and write about what's good.
I often make the joke that if we
did political history the way we do
music history we would do histories
of the 20th century and leave
out Hitler because we
don't like his work.
The thing is criticism is
about establishing what has
value in the present for us.
History is about trying to
understand how other people thought
and felt and heard things
and felt about things
in other times and situations.
They're the opposite [inaudible].
And the way rock history tended
to be done was established
with the first rock histories
in the late '60s and early '70s,
and it was establishing rock
as a serious, mature art form,
and exhibit A was Bob
Dylan and The Beatles,
and those names have forever
since ritually been put together
as creating this new music that is
maybe called rock instead of rock
and roll in the second
half of the '60s.
And in that framing Newport was --
is a confrontation between the
young exciting present represented
by Bob Dylan and the old
conservative purist folkies
represented by Lomax and Seeger.
But -- and then here, you know,
Dylan is -- Dylan, The Beatles,
The Rolling Stones, but let's take
another look at that album cover.
Dylan looks very different from
the scruffy hobo kid we remember
from the earlier '60s.
He's long-haired, fashionable,
popstar, in a rich environment.
It fits perfectly in The Stones,
Beatles narrative, but those records
that he has carefully strewn next to
him tell a slightly different story.
Eric Von Schmidt, who was
a mentor and model for him
on the early Cambridge,
Massachusetts folk blues scene,
[inaudible] singing the Berlin
cabaret music of [inaudible],
which he had gotten into
through his girlfriend,
Susie Rotolo in the early 1960's
in the village, Robert Johnson,
King of the Delta Blues
Singers, which he had gotten
into at the moment he was first
signed to Columbia Records.
The one modern record is not
The Beatles or The Stones,
it's The Impressions,
Keep on Pushing,
which incidentally not only had
been a top 10 hit that year,
but was one of the songs
The Chambers Brothers played
in their set at Newport.
So you never find histories
of the folk scene melding
with the rock scene and this
thing we called folk rock.
They don't tend to bring The
Impressions into that story,
because The Impressions are
in this separate world
that we call soul music.
I mean, as it happens,
Curtis Mayfield was known
for writing socially
conscious songs,
but he's just not typically
in that narrative.
But for Dylan himself, obviously,
the lines were being drawn
a little differently,
and apparently he wasn't alone.
I'm going to play you
something from Joan Baez
from Newport that same year.
She was on the same night
as The Chambers Brothers.
And one of the interesting things
about that weekend in 1965 is
that the weekend of the Newport
Folk Festival was also the weekend
that Lyndon Johnson announced
that he was doubling the draft
and firmly committing
the United States
to a ground war in Southeast Asia.
Virtually nobody at Newport
that weekend responded to that,
the one exception being Joan Baez,
who was probably the most
political person on that scene,
and this is how she responded.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Music ]
Okay, nothing I had ever read in
the histories of folk, rock, soul,
or pop prepared me to find Joan
Baez making her strongest political
statement of the 1965
Newport Folk Festival
by covering a recent
hit by The Supremes.
But there it is.
So why were people so upset
when Dylan played an
electric set on Sunday night?
They've had The Chambers Brothers,
they've had Joan Baez
covering The Supremes,
they've had the Butterfield
Blues Band.
The usual answer is there were a
lot of purist folkies who had come
to hold hands and sing by
Kumbaya and they didn't get it,
that however much they supported
left-wing causes they were social
conservatives and he
was a brave rebel.
There's some truth to that,
just as there's some truth
to the alternate story that they
were young leftists fighting
against racism, the war machine,
and the deadening mindlessness
of mass commercial culture, and
Dylan had gone off on a star trip
and was trying to become
a hit maker.
But, you know, the easy way
out is to say that the people
who booed him were just
stupid or out of touch.
But the fact is there were lots of
smart, aware people who were unhappy
with his set that night, and
that's why the booing mattered.
One of the reasons is a lot
of them were already upset
before he got on stage.
Remember, the founding idea
of Newport was the stars were just
there to bring in the audience,
who were then going to
discover the real folk artists.
There were these huge
evening concerts
that typically had 17,000 people,
but the meat of the festival
were the daytime workshops,
all these little stages which
normally just had two to 500 people.
You could sit up close.
You could be right at the feet of
Mississippi John Hurt or Doc Watson.
But by 1965 -- oh, I
should say also, you know,
people like Joan Baez and Pete
Seeger played along with this.
I mean, Joan Baez would show up at
the ballad workshop and she'd show
up at the kid songs workshop,
and Pete Seeger would be
on the banjo workshop, and they'd
be there framing, you know,
you like me, listen to Almeda
Riddle, listen to Frank Profit.
Dylan was an exception.
By 1965 he was not only
getting [inaudible],
not only was like a
Rolling Stone on the radio,
but he was acting like a star.
And when he showed up at Newport
he was mobbed everywhere he went.
And when he played on an afternoon
workshop on Saturday afternoon,
5,000 people showed up
and they were complaining
because like they could hear the
banjo workshop, they heard people
at the back better than they could
hear Dylan, and a lot of people
at Newport felt that the
festival was being ruined
by all these stupid pop fans
who had crowded the place
to hear the latest hit
record star from the radio,
and that these people didn't
belong at their festival.
And that went along
with other concerns
about how their world was changing.
I've -- our whole idea of the '60s,
the hippies, long hair, drugs,
rock and roll, the Vietnam
War, that's all after 1965.
The world shifts in this moment.
And, I mean, if you look at photos
of Martin Luther King's march
on Washington in '63,
it's a protest march
and everyone's in suits and ties.
That would have been
unimaginable three years later.
The Vietnam War was
just beginning in '65.
The civil rights movement
had been based on this idea
of everybody linking arms,
black and white, old and young,
marching together, the
iconic picture from 1963.
In 1964 it had reached its high
point in the freedom summer
with a lot of people from up north
going down south to Mississippi
to work on voter registration.
1965, the ghettos were
exploding, SNCC,
the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee,
which had organized
the freedom summer,
was kicking out its white members.
The new word was black power.
A lot of people have been killed,
Goodman, Schwerner, and Cheney,
[inaudible], most recently Malcolm
X. It was a frightening, scary,
difficult moment and a lot
of people had come to Newport
that weekend hoping to recharge
their batteries, to be surrounded
by other people who shared
their beliefs, get ready to deal
with what they were going to have
to deal with out there in the world,
and to link arms and
sing We Shall Overcome.
And instead Dylan was on stage alone
in the spotlight blasting the
loudest music they've ever heard
in their lives and singing How
Does It Feel To Be On Your Own,
and the answer was for a lot of
people it felt absolutely horrible.
But for most of them that was a
relatively momentary reaction.
It's important to say, I've titled
this talk, Music, Myth, and History,
and I want to emphasize
the importance of myths.
They're not the same thing
as history, but they are part
of history, and at
least equally important.
And I would say that the myths
surrounding Dylan at Newport,
or at least as important as
what he actually did that night.
What he did that night
was not a big surprise.
Everybody had heard of
Like a Rolling Stone.
It was a top 40 record right then.
What was startling was not
that he was on stage playing
Like a Rolling Stone, what was
startling and what made news,
in fact when he played on
Saturday afternoon most
of the requests you could hear on
the tape are people yelling for him
to do Like a Rolling Stone.
What made it news was
that he got booed.
The way rock historians have tended
to describe that is with an analogy
to Stravinsky's Rite of Spring,
getting booed in Paris in 1913.
Now there are lots of problems
with that analogy, but it's central
to the shift from rock and roll
being dumb teenage music to rock
and roll being serious art.
And the fact that Dylan got
booed and continued to pursue
that direction, as he was booed from
concert to concert, to Australia,
to Britain, and stuck to his guns,
proved that he wasn't selling
out to the pop machine,
that he was a serious artist
who was going his own way,
whatever his fans wanted.
And that changed the whole
perception of what rock could be.
One way to phrase that shift is
that the historians have tended
to describe that night as
Dylan's break with the folk scene,
he took the folk scene with him.
Not just all those people at
Newport who were booing that week,
but two months later loved the
stuff once they had had time
to assimilate it, but also the folk
scene's seriousness, its commitment
to ideals of authenticity, its sense
of importance in social relevance,
all that got transferred onto rock.
And to a great extent that's
the process by which rock became
and has forever since been grown
up music and college kid music.
Again, that's not a critical
judgment, positive or negative,
that's a historical judgment,
which is to say it's an attempt
to understand and explain why
certain people felt the way they
felt, thought the way they thought,
and acted the way they acted
in a particular moment.
And I'm just going
to finish by saying,
we're in a particularly
bizarre election year,
and one of the exercises
that I see very little of,
even from some people I like a
lot, is the exercise of trying
to understand why intelligent,
grown-up people might be doing
something that to you seems crazy.
And I think the value of
studying history is that you learn
that intelligent, grown-up people
over the years have constantly
made choices that to you
in retrospect seem crazy.
But if you study history
seriously you begin
to understand how had you been there
you might have made those crazy
choices yourself.
And I feel like if I've done my
book on Dylan at Newport right,
people who weren't there reading
it won't know whether they would've
been among the people
booing or cheering,
because God dammit it's complicated.
And I think that that's what the
value of the study of history is.
And with that thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
And now I'm happy to
take questions, comments.
Yes?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
You know the simple answer is
I've done my damn Dylan book
and I don't want to think about
him for a couple of years.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Absolutely.
No, no, no, I mean, clearly had I --
had the times been reversed I would
have had to make a trip to Tulsa,
which would probably
have been good for me.
>> Yeah, thanks.
>> Elijah Wald: Yeah?
>> It seems to me that another main
reason [inaudible] at this time was
to disassociate himself from the
political world surrounding folk
music, which of course
at that time [inaudible].
I don't think he was ever
that political to begin with.
I mean, you talked about --
you read [inaudible] comments
about what he really thought at
that time in the early '60s, yeah,
profound [inaudible] that is true.
>> Elijah Wald: And
poor white people.
>> Yeah, that's true.
But other than that he
was not an [inaudible],
and I think he never wanted
to be any kind of voice
in the generation, a leader --
>> Elijah Wald: Yeah.
>> Of the generation.
And they were sort of the
[inaudible] to elevate him
to this kind of, you know,
spokesman until he --
I think he rebelled against that.
He's a very private person.
>> Elijah Wald: All of that's true.
I would've said that that rebellion
had happened considerably earlier.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Elijah Wald: I mean already
when he was doing acoustic
stuff he had moved away
from the political stuff
and the folk movement.
I mean, there's this wonderful quote
that I actually use to begin one
of my chapters, that he, God
bless him, scrawled on the back
of the original manuscript of
It Ain't Me Babe, which he wrote
in a London hotel, and on the back
he writes, how many times am I going
to have to say I'm not a folksinger
before people will stop saying he's
not a folksinger.
It Ain't Me Babe, no, no, no.
Yeah, no, I mean, clearly
that had been happening
and that was part of
what was going on.
But the rock and roll thing I don't
think he went into rock and roll
to separate himself from the folk,
or that he went into rock and roll
because who the hell
wouldn't if they could.
I mean, it's fun.
>> Oh, I agree.
>> Elijah Wald: Yeah.
I mean, I think if he
could've been a rock star
in 1960 he would've been a rock star
in 1960, but the path was not there.
And when the path opened
up he followed it.
It's fun. Yeah?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> -- and I've always wondered about
how the influences really went back
and forth across the ocean.
>> Elijah Wald: Constantly, yeah.
No, I mean, look, I think
one of the horrible problems
with the way we do music history
is that there's a tendency to act
as if genres have meaning.
There is no such thing as folk rock.
I mean, this is just
a marketing term.
It's a way of selling records.
It has nothing to do
with how anything sounds.
I mean, I sometimes do the exercise
of playing Maggie's Farm the
way Dylan did it at Newport,
next to what we call folk rock.
I mean Maggie's Farm sounds
like Satisfaction more
than it sounds like
Sounds of Silence.
And The Rolling Stones were in fact
imitating -- I mean, Satisfaction,
listen to it, it's a
flat out Dylan imitation,
and Mick Jagger was
very upfront about that.
There's this wonderful
quote from Jagger talking
about Keith Richards running
into Bob Dylan in New York right
around then and Dylan saying to him,
I could have written Satisfaction
but you couldn't have
written Mr. Tambourine Man.
And the interviewer says,
well, what did he mean by that?
I mean, it wasn't a put down was it?
And Jagger says, well,
yes, of course it was.
But, you know, it's funny.
It's like -- you know, it's true.
And it is true, of course
Dylan could have written that.
And the Stones were in full scale
of Dylan imitation mode that summer.
I mean, Satisfaction, 19th Nervous
Breakdown, Get Off My Cloud,
it's all Dylan imitations.
And yet you read the histories and
like Dylan is part of folk rock
and the Stones are over in
blues rock, this is crap.
And, yeah, you know, yes, Body
and Soul is an English song,
Lime House Blues is an English song.
I mean musicians have been treating
music and styles and trends back
and forth across the Atlantic, back
at least to the minstrel shows,
and probably earlier, and it kept
happening in the '60s and '70s
and '80s, and is happening
right now.
And I just think it's completely
unuseful [phonetic] to sort
of divide these things into genres.
People are -- particularly
people who want to get
on the pop charts are constantly
listening to each other.
>> Thank you.
>> Elijah Wald: Hey, suddenly
three hands up from women.
Age before beauty, yes?
>> Thank you.
I enjoyed your talk tremendously.
[inaudible] singers.
>> Elijah Wald: Uh-huh, me too.
>> And my question to you
is did you interview any
of the people you mentioned?
>> Elijah Wald: For this
project most of the people
of that generation were
unfortunately dead.
Ronnie Gilbert was still alive
and I tried to interview her,
but she was no longer
interviewable [phonetic].
I did interview pretty
much all of those people
because 20 years ago I
was doing the research
for a biography of Josh White.
So I went pretty deep
into that world.
Yeah, I mean I talked to pretty
much all the almanac singers
who were still alive at that point,
but not specifically about this.
>> Two more questions.
>> Elijah Wald: I'm
allowed two more questions.
You're one of them,
and you're the other.
>> You talked about
imitating and training and --
but, I mean was some
of it just stealing?
I mean, did some -- were they just
taking like tunes and riffs and,
you know, from each other?
Was that okay or not frowned upon?
>> Elijah Wald: The answer to
that is extremely variable.
If I had to generalize I would say
that when somebody imitates you
and doesn't do as well as you
they are simply paying homage
in imitating.
And when somebody imitates
you and does better
than you they are stealing.
But you don't tend to know
until you see how they do.
I mean, the white singers
who covered Maybelline were
just imitating Chuck Berry
because nobody gave a damn.
The white singers who covered
Laverne Baker were stealing
because they got the top
40 hits and she didn't.
I mean, you know, it's retrospect.
You know, there's often the
saying, mediocre composers imitate,
great composers steal, and
that's sort of what we mean.
I mean, you know, once Beethoven
does it they forget that you did it,
and then you feel like
it's been stolen.
But, you know, I mean it's
complicated because like
that whole discourse is about power.
It isn't about one person
playing what someone else plays.
It's about someone with power
playing something that someone
without power plays and using
that power to get credit
that the other person
might've got, but the process
of imitation need not
be any different from --
in the one case from
the other, is my answer.
I'm sure there are others.
>> I would love to hear you say
something about Robert Plant.
>> Elijah Wald: I have nothing
to say about Robert Plant.
No, seriously, I have nothing
So I can take one more question
because I ducked that one.
Yes?
>> Your book is also
a lot about Pete.
>> Elijah Wald: My book is
very much a lot about Pete.
>> About Pete, and I thought it
was amazing the way, you know,
you said it's a complex
relationship,
but you really set
them up as [inaudible],
very political his music.
It came [inaudible] place in a
critique and Dylan really was,
you know, going his own way
at this point [inaudible] --
>> Elijah Wald: Yeah, the thing,
first of all, I made Pete the center
of this book because
-- for two reasons.
One, is I wanted to -- for
people who weren't around then,
really give them a sense of what the
folk scene pre-Dylan looked like.
And if one person ever
exemplified a scene it's Pete Seeger
and the folk scene of the
1950's in every aspect.
I mean, the amazing thing about Pete
Seeger is he had the most popular
pop folk group.
He did the most rooted
traditional music.
Pete Seeger from 1954 through 1960
released an average eight albums
a year.
He simply was folk music.
I don't care what branch
of folk music.
It all came out of Pete Seeger,
which made him just
this wonderful way
that you could exemplify a world.
But I'd like to say -- you know,
the other thing I wanted to say is
that it often -- this
thing is talked about as
if Dylan is this complicated
character
and Pete Seeger is just Pete.
You know, there was no one on Earth
more complicated than Pete Seeger.
And so part of what I was
trying to suggest in this was
that these were two very
complicated, very bright,
very interesting people, who at
this one moment went head-to-head
and represented opposite camps.
But it's just this one moment.
I mean, they remained
in touch till Pete died.
They had been very close before.
They both understood that they
were on different missions,
and they both understood that the
other was the best at doing that.
I mean, you find Dylan in the '80s,
'90s, whatever saying, you know,
what Pete does he's like a shaman.
He -- you know, he has this magical
way of bringing people together,
and rock stars don't do that.
We're just sort of living
out people's fantasies.
And you find Pete saying, you
know, I didn't get it at Newport,
but pop music was changing
into something different
from what I thought pop music was
and Dylan was instrumental
in that change.
So, you know, I was just trying
to make this story let's
just say more interesting.
And now I'm going to go out front
and I'm going to sign some books
if anyone wants them signed.
And I'm happily -- happy
to answer more questions.
I mean, I'm not going to have like
tape over my mouth or anything.
Thank you very, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.